HERE IS CORRESPONDENT
DOUG McKELWAY.
>> RUMORS OF SUPREME COURT
JUSTICE ANTHONY KENNEDY'S
POTENTIAL RETIREMENT REIGNITED
FRIDAY WHEN NEVADA REPUBLICAN
SENATOR DEAN HELLER ADDRESSED A
CLOSED-DOOR MEETING IN LAS VEGAS
CLOSED-DOOR MEETING IN LAS VEGA
LAS VEGAS.
>> REPUBLICANS HAVING AN
OPPORTUNITY TO PUT A JUSTICE IN
PLACE.
>> HE DOES NOT SERVE ON THE
SENATE JUDICIARY COMMITTEE.
KENNEDY HAS ALREADY HIRED HIS
CLERKS FOR THE NEXT SESSION.
THE HIGH COURT IS ONE OF THE FEW
PLACES IN WASHINGTON WERE
SECRETS REALLY ARE KEPT.
>> IT IS SOMETHING THAT'S
DRILLED INTO THE NEW CLERKS WHEN
THEY START.
CONFIDENTIALITY IS OF THE UTMOST
IMPORTANCE.
>> AS THEY SAY, THOSE WHO TALK
DON'T KNOW AND THOSE WHO KNOW
DON'T TALK.
>> HELLER MAY HAVE ULTERIOR
MOTIVES.
HE SAID HE HOPES A VACANCY MAY
INSPIRE VOTERS.
HE IS IN A TIGHT PRIMARY RACE
AGAINST A PERENNIAL CANDIDATE.
>> GREAT ISSUE FOR THE BASE.
THEY ARE FIRED UP BY THE THOUGHT
OF GETTING ANOTHER SUPREME COURT
JUSTICE PERHAPS LIKE JUST AS
NEIL GORSUCH.
>> IF THERE IS A SUPREME COURT
RETIREMENT, IT MAY NOT BE
KENNEDY.
JUSTICE STEPHEN BREYER 79
INJUSTICE RUTH BADER GINSBURG
TURNS 85 FRIDAY.
>> IT'S EASY TO IMAGINE HAVING
MULTIPLE NOMINEES.
ONE OF THE MOST LONG-LASTING
IMPACTS ANY PRESIDENT HAS.
>> THE TRUMP ADMINISTRATION IS
MOVING QUICKLY TO FILL 17
LIFETIME VACANCIES ON U.S.
COURTS OF APPEAL AND ANOTHER 121